are now just 10 days until the election
and the trump and biden campaigns are in
overdrive to get out the vote
president trump will hold rallies in
three crucial swing states today north
carolina
ohio and wisconsin former vice president
joe biden will make
two stops in pennsylvania the president
is waking up in another key swing state
florida our ben tracy is in west palm
beach
good morning ben good morning so more
than 5 million votes have already been
cast here in florida and president trump
plans to add one more this morning when
he casts his own ballot
presumably for himself now this is a
must win state for the trump campaign
and right now polls show
it's a toss-up hello pensacola hello
florida
at a rally in pensacola last night
president trump made it clear
he needs florida's votes 11 days from
now
we are going to win my home state of
florida and we are going to win
four more years in the white house the
president also made a stop at the
village's retirement community
despite the u.s setting a new record for
daley covid cases
the president told the crowd of mostly
vulnerable seniors
this we're not entering a dark winter
we're entering the final turn and
approaching the light
at the end of the tunnel in 2016 mr
trump won the senior vote by seven
points over hillary clinton
but the cbs battleground tracker poll
shows he's lost that advantage
and seniors now favor biden by a wide
margin the president's handling of the
virus has divided the crucial voting
bloc he doesn't wear a mask and he's
against masks
he's made a political thing out of it
honestly i think he's done a great job i
think he
he was right to not try to panic people
he tried to stay
level-headed he's quit on you he's quit
on your family
he's quit on america in delaware friday
vice president biden gave a scathing
critique of the president's response to
the pandemic
he just wants us to grow numb and resign
to the horrors of this death toll
and the pain is causing so many
americans
after thursday's debate the trump
campaign says it had its best digital
fundraising day
ever hauling in 26 million dollars much
needed cash as the president is being
badly outspent by biden's flush campaign
if joe biden is elected he'll end
fracking
the trump team is launching a new ad
blitz in the swing state of pennsylvania
seizing on these comments biden made
about the oil industry
i have a transition from the oil
industry yes
now biden later clarified that he wants
to end federal subsidies to the oil
industry not the oil industry itself and
while the biden's campaign in
pennsylvania today
they're going to get a little help from
a friend here in florida former
president barack obama will be
campaigning for him
in miami jeff ben thank you very much